Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right. What's.
Hold on guys.
This is Rob and we are back with the King in black from Marvel comics.
Something that I do want to clarify though.
I was incorrect in the first King and black video that I made that it was simply
just a one-shot the reading order I'd looked at before.
It did not show King and black parts two through five.
So I thought it was simply just a one-shot opening comic.
And that was basically it,
it turns out the King and black is an actual main series, right?
So his issues one through five, a King of black, one through five,
and then a whole bunch of tie-ins for it. So I do want to correct that. Um,
I was, I was incorrect about that.
A lot of the guys pointed that out in the comments. So thank you for that.
I would not have known had you guys not mentioned it, but, uh,
but this one kind of opens up. This is the venom tie-in right.
This one opens up basically with Eddie Brock kind of falling to his death at the
end of the first King of black story,
when Noel just stripped him of his symbiont and then dropped him.
But what this does is it initially starts out with Rick Strickland.
Now Rick Strickland was the first of the individuals out there to be bonded to
the Grendel. Right? So just kind of a reminder of the timeline here. Um, if we,
if we go on the way things used to be before Donnie Cade's venom run,
all you had was a venom Symia Davon into Eddie Brock over the years,
a lot has been done to change things.
And Donnie Cates has introduced a lot of information that we didn't previously
have. And what Donnie Cates introduced was the character of Knoll who,
by this point,
you guys should know as kind of the guy who created the symbionts,
but then also the Grendel and the Grendel was kind of a step above your regular
Simeon, right? So you have like the one that bonds to Eddie Brock,
which makes him venom,
or like the current symbiont that bonds to Cletus Cassidy,
which makes them carnage so on and so forth.
The Grinnell is kind of a step above that, right?
So if there were a hierarchy here,
he be between venom and like Knoll or something along those lines.
And even with a mat,
you have your own little hierarchy in so far as like where the venom symbionts
rank. And we might create a video like that, right?
Like ranking the venom Cypriots from strongest to weakest. But, uh,
but the idea is that Rex Strickland and his team were basically bonded to what
was the Grindle Symbion. So they were a little more powerful than venom.
Normally is there was a point where really in the beginning of Donnie Cates,
Ron, when he first started on venom,
where Eddie was contacted by Rex Strickland and then sent on a mission.
Now we ended up learning that Rex had actually bonded or really the simulated
had kind of replaced Rex after Rexha died. So he's kind of a walking,
talking symbiotic, but Eddie was still on a mission to basically save, you know,
those guys who were out there, those other symbionts,
what we never really saw was what was going on in the background while Eddie was
doing that involving Rex.
And what Rex really does is he kind of talks about the nature of Eddie. Now,
this is important because this kind of monologue that Rick Strickland offers in
the form of a diary entry kind of overlays everything that we see going on in
this comic. Right?
And so one of the things that he sort of hits out here is that sending Eddie on
this mission was almost as much of a test as it was just the need for help.
And the reason why the test aspect came in is because with Rick Strickland and
his Grendel, he became aware of the nature of Knoll Knoll's existence,
the power he possessed, and the fact that no would return to earth one day.
And so looking at that, it was kind of like, okay,
if Eddie can't do something as simple as like face off against Grendel's and
basically stop them, uh,
then what hope could he possibly have against somebody like, Nope,
but as you saw with kind of talking about, uh,
Eddie Brock him and so on and so forth,
one of the things that he talks about is flash Thompson, his agent venom,
and the flash Thompson,
his agent venom was a far more effective venom than Eddie Brock was.
Now a lot of that was because of the military training and history that flash
Thompson had.
And the fact that he was basically a government sanctioned symbiont kind of
operating out there doing his own thing, but he was a lot more effective.
He understood the necessity of nuance. He understood, uh, getting in there and,
and kind of practicing espionage, stealth tactics, different things like that.
He's not like Eddie, Eddie is a guy who just goes running in guns blazing,
right. Even if he doesn't need to. And even when he shouldn't, it's all,
he really knows, right.
He's just kind of a blunt object just attacking whatever's in front of him.
That's why a lot of fans really liked flash Thompson,
his agent venom more than that Eddie Brock,
because you got to see somebody use the venom Symbion in a way that you normally
never really see,
which is why I say we should probably cover that story if for no other reason
than the fact that it could kind of permeate and attach itself to this story
kind of bookend and show us how the other, you know,
how the Semites can be used. But at the end of the day, uh, Rex kind of, he,
he hopes the best for Eddie Brock,
but he's not a hundred percent sure that Eddie Brock can really even succeed
because looking at everything that's going on,
individuals possessed by the Grendel Symbian and all that kind of stuff.
The return of North, his fear is that Eddie will fail, right.
Will feel to rise to this occasion. And in the end,
he'll end up dying just like everybody else.
And that's kind of the thing that we get here because we transition to the
moment when Knoll drops Eddie Brock and with a quickness,
Eddie was taken over exceedingly fast.
And that's one of the big struggles that we're kind of left to solve here with
regards to the King and black story,
because what you're talking about is a being so astronomically powerful.
He was able to overtake the overtake, the Celestials that's no small feat,
right? Being able to run up on a celestial, being these guys create like,
you know, life,
they create stars and galaxies they're on par with Galactus in terms of power.
And so being able to subjugate a multitude of Celestials is not a small thing
here. So then you have like Eddie Brock with a venom Symbion and it's,
it's kind of like,
how could he possibly what we hope to stand against Knoll in the first place?
And that's the first thing that, and Kate showed us, right? No,
rip the Simeon off of Eddie Brock dropped Eddie Brock to his death.
And the semi had actually begs and pleats, right? As like, no,
like do not take me from Eddie. He absolutely needs me.
This is really one of the best developments that came from the work of Donnie
Cates.
And even some of the people that came before him with regards to the venom
stories is it gave the venom Symbion more humanity instead of it just being the
symbol, the bonnet into Eddie Brock. And it was off the Spiderman, rejected it,
going to get revenge by doing bad things.
And then eventually teamed up with Spider-Man to fight carnage.
Instead of something like that, the venom Simeon, she has a mind of its own.
It has desires. It has ambition. It wants to stay a good guy.
It doesn't want to be real kind of envelope into the fold of,
of Knoll and kind of take into a place of subservience.
It wants to keep being a good guy alongside Eddie. And that's cool.
That's a really, really amazing concept,
but ultimately the venom Symbion is seemingly absorbed by Knoll back into his
essence. And then in turn, Eddie is just kind of left to fall to his death.
Now this is probably of the most beautiful moments of this story, right?
And this is why Donnie Cates smashes it when it comes to his,
his handling of venom. So here's the thing. This is,
this is what's so cool about this stories like this.
These are the kind of stories that we reference when we do character explanation
videos or something like that, about how like a character is totally reworked.
So like when we talked about Magneto, for example,
we talked about how like with uncanny X-Men issue,
number 200 Magneto totally changed and became a good guy.
This is the equivalent of that. It's a little long,
a little more long form and so forth.
The transition of Eddie Brock becoming a good guy is certainly, you know,
happened a lot longer than the transition of Magneto,
but the principle is still the same, right?
If in 10 years we do a video kind of an updated video on venom explained,
we'll reference this, right? And we'll say like,
once Donnie Cates took over the title,
he totally changed up Eddie Brock and the venom symbiont and kind of revamped
them into a whole new format and so on and so forth.
This is what we're talking about here, right?
So you guys are kind of seeing this happen in real time,
but for Eddie Brock himself,
he kind of looks at this and literally starts to pray.
And that's something that we don't really see of Eddie because Eddie's not an
overly religious man. And just kind of says, look like, you know, I I'm,
I'm praying to whatever God is up there listening.
I'm not really worried about me. I'm probably just gonna fall to my death.
This'll be the end. But, but what I'm asking here is that you do not,
that you basically keep an eye on my kid, right? Make sure my son is okay,
that Dylan does not deserve to inherit my darkness, right? This,
this kind of horrific circumstance that I've been living in my entire life,
this desire for revenge and all this anger and wrath that I've been filled with
over the course of my life, right? This thing that's dominated me, right? This,
this thing has controlled every waking hour, you know,
everything that makes me who I am, do not let my son inherit. Now,
one thing that I do want to point out pretty much everything from the time that
Knoll drops Eddie Brock,
until we get to the end of this comic happens in the span of 32 seconds,
32 seconds. And that's all you get. And I love stories like that, right?
Where like all these things happen in the, in the span of 32 seconds. Well,
Eddie Brock's falling to his death. These symbionts of no, or are dirt, dirt,
they're getting to work, right? Like they're attacking New York. Uh,
the Avengers are all being just kind of taken over by, uh,
by the symbionts right. Spiderman is doing what he can captain.
America's doing what he can, but they're literally fighting a living army of,
of beings through almost kind of like a walking, talking liquid. It's,
it's very difficult to overcome that.
Especially when they're empowered by a guy who's a multi-vessel force of power,
right? It's not a simple thing. And so as any rock continues to fall,
he begins to realize the entirety of New York is basically lost. Right?
It's it's essentially conquered. Now, from there, you switch over to Dylan,
right? Again, this is still in the span of this 32 seconds.
You switch over to Dylan and Dylan, you know,
kind of has a radio of sorts and manages to Hijacker or somehow attach himself
to the frequency that Ironman and all the offenders are wrong.
And iron man is kinda like how in the world did you possibly get this? You know,
he's like, well, I got it from some person Spider-Man, you know,
he gets off with Spider-Man because he thinks he's the one that gave it to
Dylan. But, but at the end of the day, iron man's like, look,
you got to keep this radio channel clear, right?
Like this is how the vendors are talking to each other.
We need to know what's going on. We can't have some kid, you know,
hijacking the airways, wanting to know what happened to his death. You know,
we've got it under control. We're doing the best we can here.
If you've got a TV watch instead,
and then cuts off Dylan and Dylan starts to get off. Because when that happens,
he literally tries to reach out with his, uh,
with his ability to tap into knowledge and kind of see what's happening.
But then the actual venom Simeot itself, which is still part of no,
actually pushes out Dylan and says, no, you cannot access this.
You cannot access. No, if you access, no, he'll know where you are. Right.
You'll figure out where, where it is that you're at and he'll come for you.
Right. So not like get out of the brain of Knoll and just forefoot,
forcefully objects, him and the, you know, for, for Dylan's part,
when he was talking to the Symbian,
he felt fear when he felt fear and absolute panic.
And that's when he's kind of like, you know, my son, my connection was severed.
What did they not like? What didn't it want me to see?
And that's when he looks up at the TV and he sees no ripping off the Symbian of
Eddie Brock. Now, of course, he's seeing this after it's already happened,
but he's seeing like the symbiont being ripped off Eddie and then Eddie being
thrown to his death. And so as Eddie continues to fall,
there's actually a helicopter. This trying to outrun one of these giant,
you know, these, these Grindle's right. One of these giant, uh, you know,
Symbian bats, whatever you want to call them, send me a dragons.
Eddie kind of warns them. Like you can't out fly this thing, right?
Like you've got to just,
you literally have to land somewhere and just run for your life.
But by that point,
the dragon gets a hold of the hold of the helicopter helicopter basically ends
up crashing down and then Eddie kind of cottony explosion gets, gets set flying.
Now,
the funny thing about this is that the very fact that he was sent flying through
here starts bouncing off these, you know,
the kind of walls and things like that.
It's probably broken every single bone in his body, or at least most of them,
but he'll survive. And the reason why is because he goes crash,
landing on new a car, which is covered in symbiotic goo.
But with that being said, guys, that's where it ends this massive cliff hanger.
Uh, if you guys are new here to come and explain,
make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoy this video, make sure you drop a like,
and I gotta tell you guys, I am absolutely loving King and black.
It was every bit worth the weight. It was every ounce of worth the weight. Like,
let me know what you guys think, right. Because I love it.
Let me know what you guys think about kingdom block. You guys love it. Is it,
is it just one of the coolest things, but uh, yeah, I will catch you all later.
Bruce.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].